moïse ne croyait pas en dieu la bible
n'est pas un album tennis ce sont deux
des nombreuses affirmation étonnante du
livre qui est dieu de jean soler dont je
vais vous résumer les idées principales
je suis romain et vous êtes sur mille
idées de culture générale
[Musique]
j'ai choisi de lire ce livre quand j'ai
eu vent de la controverse quand j'ai eu
vent de la polémique créée par michel
onfray à son propos c'est dans un texte
publié dans l'hebdomadaire le point en
2012 que le philosophe avait créé la
controverse en présentant l'auteur jean
soler comme un héros intellectuelle
luttant contre l'hégémonie monothéistes
jean soler est un ancien diplomate qui
se consacre désormais à l'étude des
monothéismes à propos desquels il a déjà
écrit plusieurs ouvrages remarqués comme
si rivaliseraient pour la première fois
je me suis rendu compte que vigne aurait
presque tous de la bible du judaïsme
or de quai d'orsay m'avait nommée en
israël pour être le représentant de la
culture française et collaborer avec les
universitaires les intellectuels les
artistes les écrivains israéliens et je
me suis dit il faut que je sois à leurs
auteurs et alors je me
j'ai pensé que je devais commencer par
lire la bible entièrement mot-à-mot en
prenant des notes ce que je ne vais
jamais fne
celui ci c'est un peu la synthèse de
tous ses travaux antérieurs
je précise à ce stade que mon intention
n'est pas du tout d'entrer dans la
polémique ni de donner mon avis
d'ailleurs mes connaissances en
théologie sont plutôt rudimentaire donc
je ne prétends certainement pas faire
pencher la balance dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
je souhaite simplement proposer une
synthèse efficace de ce livre parce que
je les trouvais intéressant alors quels
sont les révélations fracassantes qu'il
contient comme d'habitude j'ai retenu
trois idées
[Musique]
pourquoi est ce que jean soler dit que
moïse ne croyait pas en dieu parce
qu'ils croyaient selon lui en un dieu
parmi d'autres petite précision si vous
ne le savez pas moïse c'est le premier
prophète du judaïsme
celui qui a reçu la loi pour cette
religion
[Musique]
je reviens à la confusion monothéisme
mono la tri d'après jean soler à lire
l'ancien testament dans un hébreu
rigoureux le dieu de la bible est un
parmi d'autres
d'ailleurs il a même un nom il y avait
qui permet de le distinguer des autres
[Musique]
c
la traduction par le seigneur ou
l'éternel dissimule en fait la dimension
profondément nationale des dieux de
cette époque dans le premier
commandement par exemple tu aimeras un
seul dieu yahvé demande en fait d'être
vénéré à l'exclusion des autres dieux
c'est ça la mono la tri et dès le
premier de tous les commandements
[Musique]
écoute israël
le seigneur notre dieu est l'unique
seigneur jean soler interprètent cela
comme la volonté des auteurs de la bible
de combattre les divinités concurrentes
en fait d'un point de vue historique les
juifs n'étaient très probablement pas
encore monothéistes quand le premier
noyau de la bible a été écrit faire
moins 620 avant jésus-christ c'est tout
simplement nous qui projetons sur les
hommes de l'antiquité nos croyances
monothéistes moderne
mais alors comment bien pu apparaître le
dieu unique
[Musique]
la première chose à prendre en compte
c'est que jean soler étudier la question
à partir de l'histoire matériel des
peuples du coup ils se méfient pas mal
des récits religieux
[Musique]
son explication à lui elle est un peu
darwiniste ce serait la pression des
circonstances historiques subies par le
peuple juif qui serait à l'origine du
passage au monothéisme
en clair comme ses croyances ne
correspondait plus à la réalité le
peuple juif aurait fait évoluer sa
religion quelles sont-elles ces
circonstances historiques si
particulière ce sont précisément 3
malheurs qui ont rendu nécessaire à
l'adaptation théologique la scission des
douze tribus mythique d'israël après la
mort du roi salomon la déportation de la
population juive de la syrie vers la fin
du viiie siècle avant jésus-christ et
enfin la conquête de la judée et la
destruction de jérusalem par le roi
babylonien nabuchodonosor or le peuple
juif avait normalement fait alliance
avec le plus grand des dieux d'après
jean soler les prêtres les prophètes et
les scribes on est donc réagi dans
l'imaginaire en forgeant des
explications ex post et en les mettant
par écrit
il se serait notamment mis à imaginer
que yahvé aurait utilisé d'autres
peuples pour punir les hébreux et qui
ensuite il aurait châtié ces peuples là
c'est comme si cette vidéo n'était
regardé par personne et je me disais
après coup a en fait c'est dieu qui
veulent châtié pour avoir parlé du livre
de jean soler donc selon jean soler ce
sont les échecs et répétées du peuple
juif à s'imposer face aux autres peuples
qui sont responsables du passage au
monothéisme
alors bien sûr cette mutation de l'idée
de dieu elle ne peut pas être datés avec
précision parce qu'elle a été très
progressive
en tout cas cette nouvelle version s'est
répandue bien efficacement parce qu'elle
simplifie le dogme et qu'elle
constituait un puissant facteur
d'unification pour l' empire romain
cependant le monothéisme a aussi bien
des défauts tout particulièrement un
[Musique]
si jean soler en veut au dieu unique
c'est parce qu'il pousse à tuer rançon
alors il ya bien le commandement tu ne
tueras point
mais en l'interprétant à l'aune de la
mono latry c'est à dire il y avait comme
dieu national du peuple juif
eh bien ça devient plus tôt tu ne tueras
point les membres de ton propre peuple
mais les autres pas peut-être que tu
peux
concernant la violence jean soler
rappelle qu'elle était très courante
dans le monde du peuple juif de l'ancien
testament on trouve d'ailleurs dans ce
livre l'ordre de mettre à mort dans le
récit du veau d'or
quand dieu ordonne à moïse de tuer tous
ceux qui ont adoré le veau en or comme
un dieu et en pratique la peine de mort
était répandu dans la loi judaïque
withelock en lançant et aux plants et
fleurs c'est houston et world échappé du
piquant dans one you lna dames ce propos
il était plus généralement quelqu'un
d'assez peu tolérant il a demandé à son
peuple d'exterminer les peuples rivaux
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas cohabiter
sur la même terre et puis le passage au
monothéisme a nécessité d'anéantir les
croyances et les représentations des
autres dieux enfin bon il n'ya pas que
le judaïsme qui soient violents bien
qu'il est érigé la non-violence en dogme
le christianisme lui aussi est devenu
violent à partir de l'alliance entre
l'église et le pouvoir politique dans la
seconde partie du premier millénaire les
croisades les chasses aux sorcières etc
tout ça est bien connu et d'une je ne
connais pas cette indécision
oh quel pouvoir s'attend vous at il
donné wael promesses diabolique vous at
il fait
et là on arrive à un des points les plus
controversés du livre selon jean soler
la violence monothéistes aurait été
recyclés dans les totalitarismes du 20e
siècle
parce que ceci ne serait en réalité que
des variantes mentale sous jacente du
monothéisme
en effet on parle parfois du nazisme et
du communisme comme des religions
séculières et l'idée est due à raymond
aron il me semble mais là où jean soler
a fait encore plus fort c'est qu'il a
rapproché le judaïsme et le nazisme
de son point de vue le peuple élu de
moïse ce sont un peu les allemands pour
hitler le séparatisme juifs renverrait
da la pureté de la race allemande et il
avance même quitte les regrets dans un
certain sens retourner contre elle même
l'idéologie venue de jérusalem on peut
comprendre que ces idées n'est pas plus
à tout le moins en tout cas pour jean
soler le monothéisme était un principe
mans intolérant quand le polythéisme lui
ignore par nature l'intolérance
religieuse
c'est pour ça qu'il en appelle à
l'esprit d'athènes pour lutter contre la
violence monothéistes qui semble
ressurgir au 21e siècle avec la
recrudescence des attentats notamment
[Musique]
alors en synthèse pourquoi ce livre est
il intéressant parce qu'il propose une
interprétation claire rationnelle et
originale de l'émergence du monothéisme
ses qualités il est court claire est
extrêmement pédagogique
il met en relation les croyances
religieuses et l'histoire matériel et
enfin il fait une critique plutôt
courageuse des religions un peu dans la
tradition des philosophes des lumières
alors maintenant ses défauts sur le fond
on peut lui reprocher d'avancer des
idées trop grosse pour être vraie même
si moi je suis bien incapable de
trancher sur la forme on peut peut-être
lui reprocher son ton de pamphlétaire et
enfin il ya quand même pas mal de
redites dans ce livre de synthèse je
pense qu'il ya eu pas mal de copier
coller mais bon on a bien droit de
s'auto plagié si vous avez aimé la vidéo
donnez lui un pouce bleus et
abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante si
vous voulez lire ma synthèse du livre de
jean soler qui est dieu voir lire le
livre directement lui-même tous les
liens sont dans la description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser vos
commentaires enfin si vous voulez
recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisée dans le format le
plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous abonner à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse email sur le
site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur
millilitres culture générale n'oubliez
pas vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]